cette herbe sauvage pousse facilement
dans les jardins à la réunion à tel
point que beaucoup la considèrent comme
une mauvaise herbe on la connaît sous le
nom 2 rbds saint paul cole cole ou
guéris vite plusieurs noms pour une même
plante plein de vertus
d'un petit planque y trouve normal en
patois la réunion dans les eaux comme
dans les bas il pousse facilement
liés et abat book c'est à peu près comme
fois et s'est améliorée ou trouve ça
dans les champs de canne trouve ça en
bordure de chemin mais il y aurait
plutôt certains endroits où trouver
soeur parce qu'ils auront dit bien
difficile pareil même problème problème
de désherbant partout notre endroit et
tout puissant
pour que sally les bons un bon peu tu as
fait un bond peu de mon nikon et à les
utiliser pour la bourboule tu vas y tu
en outils grand marmaille jusqu'à 7 ans
8 ans 10 ans 12 ans nahla bobo y donc ça
en décoction il fait beau ici en effet
le baril qu
il est bon pou problèmes de peau qu'ils
aillent bon pilote mon petit zones de
peau problèmes de peau de cole utiliser
le col cole est utilisé aussi pour tout
ce qui est petit en rafraîchissant de
monicault n'est qu'en cas trop mangé la
base et pis il prend un petit col
collera signifait bouillie et boire ça
pendant trois jours ou d'un oui bah ça
sera une journée trois grands verres ou
un demi litre 1 litre de la journée
dépend des personnes la corpulence
fitoussi j'en suis donc cole cole et
rafraîchissante donc en précisant les
anti-inflammatoires c'est-à-dire lit on
lève les toxines dans le corps et lille
est très bonne tisane pour surtout au
niveau des intestins associé avec ea
babouk tous les délits la de pair le col
cole en bain des bons pour tous les
problèmes de peau eczéma psoriasis et
tout ce qui est problèmes de
boutons d'acné aussi il peut boire une
tisane et en même temps c'est la vérité
une préparation décoction là nous va
prendre l'eau froide que les là nous
verse dans la bouilloire
et dans cette bouilloire même temps nous
va mettre des plantes décoction de zomba
ville par des kabyles et fumeterre un
dans ma ville époque là pour
laver ça nous fait un petit peu de
plantes comme ça pour à peu près un
litre et demi un litre un litre et demi
un bon litre et demi là s'est dit bien
décoction pour le bain un litre un litre
et demi ne peut rajouter un peu de pop
pop dedans on regarde bien le poids que
c'est aux phoques et octobre
mike ce n'est pas propre à la pour que
ces pays post box qui touchèrent dans le
cas rothen n'est pas dans n'importe quel
cas on compte parce que d'un poison par
les producteurs donc veillez bien à ne
pas ramasser n'importe où le pop rock
très bon pour le psoriasis très bon
poulet problème de pop lanouf un petit
préparation ne peut rajouter là dans
d'autres plantes mais là c'est pour
montrer comment nous fait une décoction
donc nous averses d'au delà versez le
dans l'eau est froide ne battait plus en
dedans
nous recouvre la casserole loire alors
ça se fait dans une grande barbe hidalgo
casseroles ne fait ça pour 5 10 litres
là c'est démonstration de chauffe nous
l'est le bouillir 1 décoction dans 5 7
minutes 10 minutes mais bon
auquel il rentre aussi dans la
préparation tisane pour bébé la petite
embarque donc c'est toujours la racine
coupé comme le zenbook que nous va
prendre coupez finement et avec d'autres
plantes pour le titan total sinon tout à
tiges et les feuilles et tous ces
poulets ben bonne petite tisane pas un
bonne poignée on met ça dans 5 10 litres
d'eau en fonction de ce que va faire
pour se laver en cas de problèmes de
peau problème de bobby et ses
calculs en interne c'est à dire quand on
a des inflammations irritation d'estomac
irritation d'être l'intestin avec ceci
avec les herbes a book très bonne tisane
pour rafraîchir dans pour nettoyer aussi
évacuer les toxines donc alcool c'est
toute la plante que les a utilisés en
fonction des problèmes des retraités
donc très bonne synergie sentent nous
sommes vraiment le le côté positif
baptisant collaborent s'assurer une
journée trois viennent ajouter 30 alveda
journée nettoyons rafraîchissant au
mieux